I think what inspires me is a mix of
them known and the excitement of
something meaning and my research focus
falls in the back-and-forth between
digital and physical looking into how
physiological information and like brain
signals electrodermal activity and any
type of physiological sensor can be used
to allow us to express in the digital
world or means that we have a lot of my
work uses dakota motifs and symbols to
show the philosophy of how we as dakota
people approach the world since coming
to MIT i've had opportunities to learn
new technologies i created a piece
specifically for this show that is a
sound vessel and it's a clay vessel that
actually transmits sound my work is
mostly oil painting one of the things
i've shown here is my subway series so
it's just basically a series of
snapshots of scenes from my everyday
commute on the red lines mostly
interested in that intersection of these
personal moments within a very public
space and kind of how they interfere
with each other I view my work as
socio-technical synthesis I'm using
geometry and exploring geometry with the
human body and also trying to focus on
emotion and sort of Gestalt shifts to
how we actually view reality
you